welcome back to another edition of the
gadget lab podcast i am michael colori i
am mike isaac i am i am
uh last week we smoked a lot of e
tobacco and giggled a lot
uh this week we're going to start off
talking about uh apis on mobile devices
and what they mean for user privacy
quite almost as crazy as the wacky
tobacco yeah maybe the exact opposite
but uh halfway through the show we are
going to do a product giveaway so stay
tuned yes yes stay tuned it's a fancy
product an expensive fancy product that
you can win
and we're gonna bring christine on to
talk about ipad
rumors
uh first up though is the story of path
yeah mike why don't you tell us what
happened i will talk about it so path
i mean it sounds like a little weird
right you know there's also a social
photo sharing app right for those of you
who don't know yeah path is a is think
of instagram meets foursquare meets
facebook
it sort of takes all of these social
apps and brings it into one place right
they relaunched uh in uh i believe late
last year uh which we wrote about and uh
they sort of redid their whole app they
made it really attractive they just won
an award for their design it is very
pretty it's very it's an elegant app
it's what they say um
so it was doing great you know it got a
lot of great uh attention and then
earlier this week it was discovered by
some random developer out there in the
ether that path is actually pulling your
address book information from your
iphones not on android but on your
iphone uh and and uploading it to their
servers oh yeah exactly
so you wouldn't talk to the ceo about
this yeah so we got
an exclusive interview with um dave
moran who's the ceo of path and he
basically laid it all out for us they
they did a big blog post too that the
headline was
we're sorry we made a mistake we screwed
up right so they made a mistake by
actively
making their application grab all of my
data right from my address book so they
know the phone numbers and the email
addresses of everybody that i know right
and they pulled it into their server and
they hold on to it and whoopsie that was
a mistake yeah so what do you think do
you buy i mean yeah exactly that was the
first thing i asked him is like if you
know you guys are a million
multi-million dollar outfit who with
very smart people who know what they're
doing how is this a mistake you know how
did this happen
part of it what what he told me what
dave told me was that some of the
features that are integrated into path
like uh
this thing they called friend rank
requires the use of your uh address book
data so they they're able to suggest the
top friends that you want to connect
with on path based on this data inside
of your address book doesn't matter
right i mean this doesn't matter don't
treat the messenger this is what what i
really want to talk about is the wider
implications of this the context in
which this controversy exists that's
more interesting which is that
if something like this which
many people not everybody many people
would consider a gross invasion of one's
privacy
um features like this that rely on
address book data should be opt-in right
so that was the biggest sort of
complaint like okay at least put it to
us up front whether or not we can we
have to share this information yeah this
wants full access to your address book
data is this okay yes or no exactly
um
on install when you turn that feature on
it's off by default you know there are
many different ways to handle it um are
there other apps that that are guilty of
doing the same thing yeah totally this
was the other point that uh that many
have made out there facebook did this
two years ago facebook is no stranger to
privacy issues uh
some random ceo of this app called
hipster which is like the dumbest name
for an app i've ever heard of just
something you know but i could think of
development this is a guy with tattoos
and plaid shirts uh uh
uh they they also apologize they
apparently were doing this too and it
seems like a lot of them are kind of
like whoops we are doing this but
i have a hard time buying that this is
all just like a big mistake right i
think what what the issue really is is
that app part of it is that apple
doesn't
in strict language require this of
developers and when they're you know
creating their apps require you to ask
for
uh an opt-in policy as far as pulling
address data right so this this is
probably all going to change now right i
would guess i would hope so right the
paths and the facebooks and the hipsters
of the world are going to be forced to
be a lot more um uh forthcoming about
exactly what they're collecting what
they're doing with it
um the oh but we didn't mean any ill
will excuse is probably not going to fly
anymore right um because we've
everybody's sort of learned their lesson
by watching path grow up in public and
maybe apple will make changes to its uh
to its uh
ecosystem inside the phone and apis that
developers use
to require that sort of um
data gathering data gathering
to be um opt-in yeah i mean and android
already has this sort of security built
into it actually that you're required i
think in the
sandboxing techniques you're required to
ask for permission if you if you want to
access this sort of data so maybe this
will push
ios into doing the same thing yeah the
way it looks like if you're going gonna
walk up and touch a stranger you should
probably ask right
you're supposed to ask me yeah okay
anyway
um now we're gonna uh give away
something really fun and exciting what
is it uh it's an iphone case
that's what we're giving away
you made people sit in your path for
five minutes
for an iphone okay all right it's
actually very cool case from
a company
called um element case and it is the
brand new vapor pro case
it is made of machined aluminum
and it is very lightweight and it is
very sexy it is very slim and it is very
expensive uh these cases run about
eighty dollars ninety dollars a hundred
dollars in that neighborhood you get
them from different retailers but yeah
so basically what it is yeah what is it
like a shock proof thing yeah it's a big
bumper so it's a big aluminum bumper
that sits around the outside of your
iphone 4 iphone 4s
um it exposes it has little holes to
expose the uh you know the different
ports um the buttons the switches and it
also has this handy little
plastic piece that fits over the gap in
the antenna so it eliminates the death
grip problem the uh the antennagate deal
yeah yeah
the death grip i prefer to call it um
i'm rocking sort of the bumper look
right now it also comes with a
small plate that you can put in the back
so you can have protection on the back
to protect it from scratches it also
comes with a
a really nice rugged
screen cover to protect against
scratches on the screen
it's easily the nicest screen cover that
that i've used although i took it off
pretty soon after testing it uh and it
comes with a sort of hardened shell case
for carrying around your phone
uh for added protection when you're in
transit okay now all of this adds up to
like i said you know around 100 bucks a
little less than 100 bucks depending on
where you get it
a little more than a hundred dollars
outside of the country made in the
united states
but i will say that i'm not really a big
fan of cases uh i went caseless for a
very long time
there's a couple of in cases that i like
that are really slim that offer a little
bit of protection on the phone but in
general i feel like cases had too much
bulk when they're in your pocket this
one
adds bulk so i'm probably not going to
keep it on the phone
but
it does provide outstanding protection i
put it on my girlfriend's phone this
weekend and we went to the bar and she
dropped her phone three times
and it was unscathed how long were you
there oh
like eight hours or something i don't
remember you know it's all blurred nice
uh anyway if you'd like to win one of
these vapor cases we're not giving away
this white one because it's it's been
used already and it's kind of dinged up
but we are giving away a brand new
untouched unworn black ops case which is
black with sort of a yellow death grip
protector and uh to win it all you have
to do is hit us up on twitter at gadget
lab yeah at gadget lab and tell us what
mike isaac should get tattooed on his
head
now mike has a lot of tattoos and he's
he just got a few new ones this weekend
which he's not going to show you right
now i can't show you them legally fcc
or producers right veto exactly um so
the winner mike will either get the
thing that you suggest tattooed
somewhere on his head
or
he will choose to send you the uh vapor
pro case right it's up to you
no it's up to you oh yeah it's up to me
it's up to you so either you get a
better idea you get a new tattoo or the
person gets a case so either way you win
exactly
uh and
in either way i don't know we all win
right we all win just suggest what you
think would be good and then i will i
will choose it at gadget lab reply to us
yes at gadgetlab on the twitter yeah so
now we're going to bring on christina
and we're going to talk about ipad
3.
hey i have a question yes what's cooler
than the ipad 2
it's got to be the ipad 3. oh is there
an ipad 3 now
not yet but there's parts maybe of an
ipad 3
so this week we saw leaked images of the
rear casing of what could be the ipad 3.
where these come from china yeah
insiders
insiders in the supply chain twitpix
yeah
yeah but so
looks like the ipad 3 could look very
much like the ipad 2 maybe with a
slightly larger battery
a different processor different camera
um basically
souped up inside specs
so um one of the rumors that i was
reading about was that there's going to
be an updated version of the display
right yes so sharper higher resolution
yeah possibly retina display quality
okay now it's not hd now right so it's
possible that we could get an hd version
yes yeah and so some people are actually
debating whether this is going to be
like the ipad 3 or the ipad hd or some
other name you know how about the ipad
2s
that's what i was thinking too or maybe
it could be like
the ipads we really think that g plus
are you really thinking about the two s
maybe so i don't know
sorry i just think that would be bad it
would be bad maybe like the xl or anyway
um
so
the thing the other thing i'm looking
forward to is possibly uh price drop
because of everything that's happened in
the last year with the kindle fire and
with the the nook tablet and all the
other 200 devices coming out now do you
think apple's in a position position
where they
just say to hell with it we're just
going to leave it at 500 bucks or do you
think they're really feeling pressure to
maybe drop the price down i think
they're totally at liberty to keep at
the same price because people are going
to buy it for that price but they could
maybe lower the price of the ipad 2 down
to maybe like half price or a hundred
bucks off or something three or four
hundred dollars so i think if they're
gonna make a cheap ipad they're just
gonna drop the price of the ipad too
what about educational pricing
that's a good question i mean they are
pushing the ipad for education
um especially with the whole like ibooks
announcements
um
i think maybe it'll just be
priced down ipad 2s rather than a
cheaper ipad 3 2s 2xl well either way
i'm going to line up for one yeah and
might be coming
it might be coming as soon as the first
week of march i believe it because
it would make sense for them to do the
pop-up store at south by southwest
interactive which starts i think on the
9th or the 8th of march yeah and that's
around the time that they've announced
it the past two years so well i'll be in
texas so
i know what i'll be writing about that
week the ipad 3 yeah i'll be writing
about apple's pop-up store where
everybody's going to be lining up and
buying their ipad so if you're there say
hi you know what i look like
that's all for this week
next week we can't promise that we're
going to bring you three stories related
to apple products but the way things
have been going
you